in today's morning rounds were focusing
on Mental Health Awareness Month which
starts today a new study out this
morning in the Journal of Pediatrics
finds the number of suicides between two
thousand and two thousand eighteen by
self poisoning mainly through overdoses
has soared especially among teenage
girls the American Psychiatric
Association says one out of every six
people will suffer from depression at
some point in their lives CBS News
contributors psychologist Lisa d'amour
and dr. David agus join us this is such
an important conversation but I have to
ask Liz just even on the basics I mean
teenagers are known to be very secretive
I mean how is it that you parse if
someone is just kind of feeling the
blues versus being clinically depressed
and needing to go get help sure sure so
the way we want to think about this
is that mental health is like physical
health mentally healthy people get sick
they get down they feel sad and they
recover in the same way that physically
healthy people get sick and recover what
we worry about is when people become
upset and they stay down and they cannot
pull themselves out of it in the same
way we would know someone was really in
trouble physically if they became ill
and got ill ur
Ann Diller David how difficult is it to
diagnose or measure mental health to
begin with it is one of the greatest
problems I see is that this amazing
organ you know mental health is a big
issue but the greatest technology I have
to know whether you have mental health
is forwards how do you feel we have no
way of actually measuring the brain the
next frontier over the next decade will
be figuring actually how to quantify in
the end measure the brain there are
standardized questionnaires and ways
doctors do it today and we have
treatments that work but actually
measuring the brain is going to be wild
and what it can do for us and such a
spectrum - of mental health no question
of bucket eyes things now right now
you're depressed you're this you're that
they're probably gradations there's a
spectrum of each of these disorders and
when you measure things you have an
optimization parameter at least I'm
picking up on that way mentally there is
a still a stigma about mental health we
don't have our kids go to have a mental
health check-up the way we have them go
get a physical even though there's
nothing wrong with them
they go to have their physical so talk
about that a little bit so the problem
with mental health is that it really
it's how you feel and how you're
thinking and so when people's feelings
and thinking isn't what they want it to
be they have the sense that they should
be able to pull themselves out of it to
sort of shake it off and the problem
with clinical depression is you can't
shake that off any more than you could
shake off a broken leg and so we have a
lot of work to do to help people
understand that depression is an illness
in the same way that pneumonia is an
illness and just as we can treat
pneumonia we can treat depression
and so doctor how do we treat it yeah
think about shaking off a broken leg you
know there's this simple notion we say
well it's a chemical imbalance in the
brain which is totally wrong right
certainly neural chemicals these
molecules are very do control how we
feel our emotions and how we respond to
things the drugs we have they work they
change some of these chemicals but it's
not that simple most of these drugs take
weeks to a month to work so it's not
just giving a chemical it may be
creating new neuronal connections we
don't understand necessarily how all of
these work but they work psychotherapy
medications work avoidance people with
medical problems whether it be low
thyroid or heart disease higher
depression when you don't sleep
depression goes up when you're indoors
we call seasonal affective disorder
there's not a lot of sunlight depression
goes up so address the things that are
addressable discuss it with your doctor
and talk about potential treatments if
it's appropriate why is this such an
acute problem though among teenagers and
particularly teenage girls I mean how
much of just fitness can there be to
avoid this well one thing we want to be
clear about is that teenage girls and
this has been true for a long time of
girls and women are more likely to
attempt suicide boys and men are more
likely to complete suicide why is that
they tend to use more lethal methods and
so what we see is more attempts among
girls and women but more completion
among boys and men and so the rates
actually can be a little bit confusing
in that way we don't actually know what
accounts for the spike it's very hard
for us to make sort of clear causal
assumptions here
the thing you said about sleep though is
one thing that we're really starting to
worry about we are watching sleep let on
prosign by the way I'm all for sleep I'm
all for sleep but we're watching sleep
levels decline and when people sleep
less depression goes up and when
depression goes up suicide goes up way
not good where I have to take that in
for a second we just think about the job
the hours that we have at a job we have
yes and also important and the pressures
on kids and the fat of phones that keep
them awake at night to keep them from
sleep we do an entire new generation
that has grown up with the screen that
is affecting the wiring of the brain
that blue light your brain says hey
that's daytime and it changes how we
think and how we're wired we don't know
the implications or what's going to come
from that you've got to have and you
have to have the conversation a
difficult conversation get this on a
talk about house but I love that you're
wearing green Garib mental health they
do do it's great but everywhere in green